en attendant je vais vous présenter une
équipe qui ne s'en tire pas trop mal
puisque l'équipe du splendid et
subventionné d'abord par les spectateurs
et puis ensuite par les producteurs de
cinéma depuis les bronzés nous on n'est
pas à subventionner par eux ont
travaillé mais si la paix le théâtre et
le sud est de recevoir un peu d'argent
oui mais ça fait vivre l'argent pour
manger
bon c'est sûr via le cinéma permet de
faire du thé à ce oui c'est un luxe
voilà alors je préviens tout de suite
les les enfants qu'ils risquent d'être
un peu traumatisé par le titre de votre
prochain ce mec tu parles à pied souci
par la pièce aussi enfin le titre déjà
oui ça s'appelle le père noël est une
ordure
bon vous êtes les premiers à proférer ce
genre d'accueil en mai parce que c'est
vrai parce que dans la pièce le père
noël qui est jouée par mois et c'est une
ordure c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle
comme ça ce n'est pas du tout une
atteinte à son image il croit toujours
se traduiront lit dans votre regard
sinon alors comme toutes les vraies
pièces comiques celle ci exploite un
thème dramatique profondément c'est
complètement désespéré pièce désespéré
qui fait rire oui c'est la nuit de noël
c'est la nuit de noël à détresse amitié
détresse amitié c'est une un organisme
où les gens peuvent appeler quand ça va
pas il cherche un réconfort et puis là
comme celui de noël bas ils vont réussir
à se glisser à passer puis à tout un tas
de plaisir que les fans pas la nuit de
noël ils viennent téléphone qui viennent
alors on va essayer de présenter
quelques-uns des
prix des protagonistes de ce spectacle
si dramatique alors vous vous êtes le
père noël oui oui je suis une ordure que
vous d'où le titre oui je suis un
parasite quoi faut dire que j'ai
beaucoup d'excusés parce que j'ai une
jeunesse difficile j'étais orphelin à 6
ans et puis j'étais refusé comme pilote
de ligne à cause de l'orthographe
oui ça vous marque alors à côté de vous
anémone qui est une des deux répondent
deux c'est à dire celles qui en principe
prend le téléphone oui et que c'est très
bonne je profite des montagnes pour
tricoter dégâts à trois doigts pour les
télés près de jakarta j'ai moi même bien
du malheur et je n'ai plus de vie de
femme depuis trois ans d'ailleurs je ne
m'en porte pas plus mal mais voilà j'ai
coincé
oui enfin si vous n'avez plus de vies de
femmes votre voisine en à une sauce soja
vie du tout moi je n'ai plus goût à rien
oui alors roland giraud bien le rôle du
travesti et maintenant 8 août cellules
qui se respecte il faut un travesti oui
mais moins c'était la suite d'une
sinistre affaire enfin moi j'ai été
mariée mais depuis que thérèse
m'acquitter je n'ai plus goût à rien et
c'est une catastrophe à la suite d'une
affaire de manteaux prêter rendu tâche
et l'affairé un manteau ni valeur
inestimable
j'ai été obligé n'ayant pas de fortune
personnelle de faire tous les métiers du
monde et jusqu'aux plus anciens et j'ai
vendu mon encore qui en voulait et y
croyez moi ils n'étaient pas nombreux
oui bah oui effectivement c'est toujours
la loi de l'offre et la demande
et enfin enfin
marie-anne chazel qui est moi je suis
d'ailleurs son tour de taille le montre
la femme enceinte
voilà alors moi je suis la fiancée de
félix le père noël et puis sur la 3g
beaucoup de malheur parce qu'il ya ici
de me faire passer par le vide ordures
et forcément ça passait pas heureusement
parce que je suis enceinte jusqu'aux
dents alors vous avez compris à quel
point vous sauriez mue en allant voir
cette pièce la troupe étant complété par
un monsieur en robe de chambre qui bruno
moynot et qui est le voisin du dessus
c'est ça chez le voisin du dessus je
suis un peu désespérée que je suis un
immigré suis loin de mon pays je
descends pour avoir un peu de contacts
je viens offrir des chocolats nqi son
très bon parce que c'est des choses qui
viennent directement de mon pays c'est
du caca ou de synthèse la saccharose de
la margarine c'est que des bonnes choses
oui de bismuth c'est pour pour le voyage
pour que ça se garde sont obligés d'en
but les notations d'ailleurs
intéressante
dans ce texte il est prouvé dites-vous
statistiquement qu'il y a deux fois plus
de suicides chez les désespérés que chez
les autres
oui oui mais voilà ça méritait d'être
dit parce que quelquefois on hésite un
petit peu bon eh bien messieurs en
attendant la subvention il reste à
souhaiter que la grille tic le public ou
même le public seulement se presse s'est
déjà fait pas puisque déjà ça va